what do you want to do what should we do
because
this is also affecting me a lot and i'm
starting to feel really
bad here like is this is all because of
me
i don't want to destroy your family you
know what i'm saying i i don't want to
be responsible for all of this pain it's
not to use causing anything like
we always see this kind of stuff in our
house
and i don't know like you know
why i i used to lie a lot
because this is something i learned from
my own family
my father he always surrendered in front
of my mother and
that's what he
told us like okay just maintain peace
give up in front of your mother
whether we find that she's right or
wrong she's the boss
lie
or suffer that is crazy man that is just
i i can't even comprehend it
i i really don't like to lie
i want to stand up and say whatever i
feel like
but we grew up in a way that we start
lying in order to avoid the situation
and that is the reason uh till now like
me and my parents don't talk much about
serious
hard stuff
i know my mom loves me my my father
loves me but i feel that my mom's love
is so big the fees that whatever
she's saying me it's the only good way
for my life for me to live a good life
my divorce was one of the biggest
laws of my mother she was very happy
with the girl
like he helped her in domestic help
and stay with my mom talk to my mom my
mom feels very happy
just like
missing a girl
a daughter in her life
and my
sister she passed away when she was
eight month old so i don't know if she
had like some
uh desire she thinks that she want to do
she wasn't able to do then she thought
she gonna do it with the daughter she
feels like that i'm
like i divorce her and
i like snatch my mom's happiness
[Music]
i do had a younger sister one and a half
year younger to me
uh she died because of jaundice and this
explained the way my mother blamed me
for losing another daughter
when i get divorced
sometimes it feels like my mother is
taking revenge like hey
she is mad at me because she's not happy
she lost a girl she had connection with
so maybe it's explained that's why my
mom don't like jenny because she
uh like consider jenny as like a one who
helped me
in order to get divorced
[Music]